our buddy from bleach report Howard back
joining us from New York City back here
on the Rich Eisen show fresh off of
posting yesterday a column an article
entitled NBA execs skeptical Lakers can
build a tidal team after Anthony Davis
overpay I know you don't usually write a
headline when you write the article but
that's saying a mouthful right there
Howard why are NBA executives so
skeptical right now yeah you're rich I
don't think they're skeptical at the
Lakers can build entitled a skeptical of
their ability to build period now when
you start with LeBron James and Anthony
Davis you're already like you know 75 80
percent of the way there and you're
already probably in contention but they
have three players when this deal is
done
as it's currently constructed and that's
LeBron Anthony Davis and Cal Kuzma
that's fine but you know you might need
a point guard in a shooting guard and
some guys off the bench who can score
and defend and rebound and make plays
and occasionally give LeBron a breather
there's a lot of building left to do so
the point is this let's leave the trade
aside for the moment I'm sure we'll get
back to the actual pieces but when you
look at what the Lakers have and what
they need to do to create a team there's
a lot of vacancies they have somewhere
between 23 and 32 million depending on
how this trade Oakland unfolds and
there's a lot of places spots to fill
now LeBron in his prime even at you know
27 you still needed a supporting cast
whether he was in Cleveland Miami or
wherever you know the heat don't win
those titles without Shane Battier and
Mario Chalmers Rashard Lewis Ray Allen
they're gonna need a supporting cast and
so there's a lot of work yet to do there
Rob the link in his brief time with the
Lakers has not shown the ability to
build a team he has in fact you know
last summer under Rob and Magic Johnson
at that time they had one of the most
baffling off seasons we've ever seen
aside from signing LeBron so it's one
thing to get the star who already wants
to come to your to your city in to your
choice to come they did that with LeBron
they did it again with Anthony Davis
it's another thing to actually have a
plan and the ability to build out a
roster and that's kind of important I
mean again they're way ahead
the game by having the two players they
have they need to build a team well and
in terms of in terms of that like look
we I don't think there's any argument
about how poorly this the roster was was
we woven here in Los Angeles last year
there's there's no question about that
and there's every reason to question
palinka z-- you know talent I in order
to put one together here no question but
I don't want to read on our line from
your piece that was right down at the
bottom just as alarming because you're
talking about how alarming it is after a
quote saying never let your GM be in a
spot where he needs to take it make a
trade to save his job as a reference to
palinka just as alarming the Lakers
seemingly put no thought into the timing
of the deals execution potentially
costing themselves around nine million
in salary cap room is polenka really
just that clueless that he would not
even pay attention I mean he was an
agent for a while would he be really
that without a clue Howard well there's
a huge difference between being an agent
and being a general manager huge
difference and you know let's list a
couple of examples of guys who have made
that transition well because people will
immediately point to Bob Myers at the
Warriors Bob Meyers stop being an agent
went and spent a year apprentice thing
essentially with the Warriors before he
took over as general manager Neil Shaye
went to the Los Angeles Clippers under
Mike Dunleavy and spent I think multiple
years actually within their front office
learning the ropes before Neil took over
as the Clippers GM and then ultimately
of course he's with Portland now pálinka
went straight there he went straight
there with magic who also had never done
the job the salary cap and the CBA it's
monstrous it is so detailed so layered
so confusing that and then complex you
don't just absorb that overnight and if
you don't have a great staff and this is
the other problem then you're prone to
making mistakes like not realizing that
the timing of the trade would matter in
terms of how much capper Mew could
preserve and you miss things like oh
Anthony Davis has a four million dollar
trade kicker you before you consummate
the deal with the pelicans you should
seek permission from them to speak with
Anthony Davis and his reps to say listen
we'd like you to waive the trade ticker
as a condition of coming because that
four million could help us get you a
better supporting cast the problem is if
you consummate the deal first and then
you try to do it go oh I guess we should
have considered that well now now he's
basically I'm to give money back but if
you do it at the front end as part of
the negotiation you're in better shape
and the pelicans are incentivized
to help them on that if you ask them at
the the front of the deal because the
pelicans are the ones who actually have
to pay the trade kicker even though it
goes on the Lakers cap is it's a cap hit
for the Lakers right it's my question
out for you just hearing all this RT
interrupts III love the backcourt that
you and I have here is that this is a
clutch sports creation right I mean what
do you think rich Paul and and and and
Anthony Evers are gonna come to the
Lakers and then hamstring plinkus
ability to build a championship game for
LeBron over four million dollars I mean
that that's what some of this stuff just
doesn't compute to me Howard yeah rich I
mean it's look you're you're right but
here's the thing
players take and I don't want to ever
want to get into a whole thing about
what players are you know what they owe
their teams or what they don't almost up
a players take the max all the time
knowing full well that that money that
max contract that they've earned will
also hamstring their teams
it's just baked into the system every
dollar you earn is a dollar that's not
available for the team to spend under
the salary cap or possibly under the
luxury tax threshold it's just baked
into the system so if you tell somebody
this is what we're gonna offer you
you're never gonna say no but if you if
you presented it in a different way
listen here's what we're offering you
but if you took a couple million less if
it'll help us sign some guys and that's
what the heat did with LeBron and Dwyane
Wade and Chris Bosh back in 2010 it
helped them get Mike Miller and help
them resign Udonis Haslem but you've got
to do that at the front end and so in
this case it's a trade kicker the kicker
is is only worthwhile if he's traded so
it's money he doesn't have yet but once
you've consummated the deal and now he's
expecting to get it now you're asking
him to reverse that and look you're
right
he should have incentive as LeBrons new
teammate to give the Lakers all the
latitude in the world
to help the two of them get a better
supporting cast but he's not obligated
to it's in his contract to get that four
million and it's a lot of money to just
give up so it should have been broached
beforehand and my understanding as of a
couple days ago is that that
conversation not only hadn't happened
before the consummation of the deal
verbally but still had never been
discussed okay so then we're where do
things stand right now how are back of
bleacher report as we're gonna see a
fourth overall pick is going it's gonna
happen at some point the fourth overall
pick is going to be on the clock and
it's gonna be a transacted the question
is is for home when do we find all this
stuff out Howard what's the timeframe
here well I feel bad for the fourth pick
whoever that might be because they're
gonna go across the stage and be
announced as being a Laker they're gonna
put on a Laker hat and the first thing
is going to be is so where do you think
you're really going you know are you New
Orleans pelicans or the pelicans
flipping that pick again which is a
decent bet I don't know where that
fourth pick is going or who it will be
and I'm not sure when we'll actually
know because you know there's the draft
tonight for agency doesn't start until
you know whatever they've now made it 6
p.m. on June 30th technically or
whatever the moratorium the a
theoretical moratorium where you
quote-unquote can't do deals doesn't
lift until July 6th and that is as of
right now when this trade should go
through so there's just a lot of time
left and different trigger points here
I'm not sure when we'll know the the
reality of it all I suspect that if they
rework the deal to try to like delay the
execution till later in July or whatever
else like that stuff will leak out soon
enough
I imagined and what what would be the
pelicans and I guess this is the point
of your article that so many NBA
executives are saying why didn't the
Lakers hammer all this stuff out before
saying yes so what would the pelicans
what skin in their game do they have to
let the Lakers get this transaction
happening as late as possible this is
the funny part so well it's not fun if
you're a Laker fan or if you're the
Lakers one eye
again these are things that they should
have broached beforehand and not gotten
to this point because now you're going
back to David Griffin that's the
pelicans GM insane Derrick Griffin we're
a little bit of a bind here we could use
an extra nine million in cap room and we
can't get it unless we push back this
deal and griffiths meanwhile saying no
no listen I got other things lined up
here I want to put the fourth tick that
teams gonna want to sign that guy you
know we can't wait on that they're gonna
want that guy at Summer League
we can't just like delay this whole
thing and so then the Lakers are say
alright well alright what's it gonna
take
and now you're back to negotiating and
now the pelicans are back to being in a
position where they can extract even
more from you than they already have the
weather is what's left I don't know I
mean another pic swaps somewhere in
there there's still Koosman I guess I
don't think they're going to give him up
like they're just this is why you need
an experienced hand doing this this is
why when magic step down here's the
irony here's the irony the Lakers got
schooled on this deal when it from a
negotiating standpoint again as I wrote
they won the trade they got Anthony
Davis they got the best player
they got a top whatever top five they
lost the negotiation and they did
because they got schooled by a better
more experienced GM David Griffin who
the Lakers could have hired after magic
step down and instead they decided to
stick with everybody they had promoted
Rob palanca I've asked around who is
advising him who do they have to
navigate things like tricky cap wrinkles
and and things like trade kickers and
all these little details that can they
can get by you because you need a strong
staff and I don't I haven't forgotten
any good answers from anybody so they're
a bit of a bind but at the end of the
day look they're still going to have
Anthony Davis and that shouldn't get
lost in all of this and I do want to
make very clear to like this isn't just
my judgment about how the trade went
down or whether they lost the
negotiation this is everybody I've
talked to around the league is pretty
much universally seeing this as the
Lakers did not do this well well what
about the idea that the people are gonna
want to play with LeBron James and
Anthony Davis and the narrative of a
week ago that the Lakers were a dumpster
fire that no one would want to come
and that if they totally whiff on
everything that the future of LeBron
James and Los Angeles would even have to
be put in a question that's all gone now
that's gone
heading into July first right yep no
listen they this is this is a great
palate cleanser um not only game but
it's certainly not Laker fans are gonna
forget anytime soon what's going on the
last few months and how bad things have
been and I would say it's still kind of
a wait-and-see I mean look getting
ethany Davis puts you back in contention
it restores some credibility but that's
why again to the to the anonymous GM's
that I quoted in the piece that's why
you don't have somebody who's under the
gun I mean look if it was a bit of
hyperbole by the one GM to say you know
your job being on the line Rob FeliCa
probably was going to be getting fired
if he didn't pull something off this
summer but he certainly is under immense
immense pressure to get LeBron James
help to save face to make the Lakers
look respectable again in the wake of
all the nonsense that's gone on in
recent months and that pressure had did
come to bear that pressure is evidenced
in the results of this trade in which
they gave up almost every trade asset
that they had including pics that leave
them encumbered with regard to pics all
the way until potentially 2025 so
there's just a lot of downside risk
there and they gave up more than they
should have needed to so Howard back at
bleacher report before I let you go
let's talk Rockets a little bit here I
want to walk you through a few things
and if you can quickly as best you can
tell me what what sits close to the
truth or not first things first the
relationship between Chris Paul and
James Harden has reported by Yahoo is no
longer reconcilable what do you think I
mean listen there's more reporting than
just ads at espn.com McMahon had an
extensive article about their their
frayed relationship to so you know
whether it's frayed whether it's
irreparable whether it's however you
want to classify it there's clearly a
problem there and there were a lot of
like public you know bits of evidence
just in terms of their interactions
postgame and in games there's tension
there now you can win despite the
tension but you know this but this is a
too much smoke to not be fire situation
and you know the Rockets clearly are
looking too
Chris Paul there's multiple reports
about that they're in a tough spot and
it's not just that they don't have
enough firepower and a lot locked up in
an older Chris Paul is that yeah they're
two stars don't seem to be enjoying each
other anymore all right give me the
best-case scenario who would be able to
acquire Paul I mean who would want him
and who has the ability to pull off the
trade assets for Daryl Morey and then
they they hold fitting his monster
salary under the cap I don't know I just
don't know it's a huge salary no one's
gonna be able just absorb it you're
gonna have to find a way to to you know
make a deal where you're at least
getting close to matching the salaries
does anybody want Chris Paul at this age
on that number
you never say never every time we say
there's an in tradable contract somebody
gets traded anyway so you know but that
this was a really high bar I mean if
you're asking me is he a rocket next
season I say yes okay and then last one
for you on this front is what about
capella dude are the Rockets a trade
player tonight what happens this evening
if they can find a way to trade capella
here's the thing I keep seeing people
throw out capella scenarios that don't
end up with the Rockets actually moving
forward they're gonna flip capella who's
a decent young big and a good dive man
in the pick-and-roll you need to at
least get back a player or players who
are helping you now this isn't going to
be a situation where you're just dumping
his contract and getting some you know
picks or you know fringe guys they know
that the Rockets still want to contend
as long as they've got James Harden and
certainly as long as they're stuck with
Chris Paul too so I don't know what the
right deal there is I don't know if this
is just going to be a reshuffling of
deck chairs but they're kind of stuck
they don't have a lot else that's
movable they don't have a lot to work
with but daryl morey just creative and
aggressive as they come and you know
maybe he doesn't pull off something
tonight but probably something in July
and then tonight give me a prediction of
craziest rumor that has a chance to come
true and if you're right we'll replay it
and if you're wrong this is this
conversation never happened Howard
oh man I don't even know where to begin
with that one I I'm trying I'm trying to
think about what the most spectacular
thing that could possibly because I'm
thinking you know obviously already
thinks it's chalk top three tonight and
then there might you know there could be
tons of trades involving players of
significance or there could be nothing
so if something totally goes off the
rails tonight give me your best
prediction on that if you can if you
don't it's all good and if you're right
will retag know if it's wrong and don't
worry I was creative enough to come up
with something like that on the fly I
think there are three teams I would
watch for aggressive moves tonight that
might that might surprise us or that
might upend things okay um
Toronto because Masai Ujiri knows
whether the Kauai stays or goes he's got
some Aging issues and Parsons that
roster and I wouldn't be surprised to
see Masai makes some bold move tonight
the Rockets for sure as we've mentioned
and then always keep an eye on Danny
Ainge and the Celtics especially with
the moves that are happening now where
they're expecting to lose Kyrie and
expecting to lose Al Horford and they
got a kind of retool on the fly those
are the teams I would I would keep an
eye on
well done Howard thanks to the call
brother enjoy tonight we'll chat soon
always play the rest think that that's
Howard Beck bleacher report at Howard
back on Twitter for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
under red TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app